[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of things have happened in america
this week it seems like every time i
checked the news there was another huge
story but aaron burr told me tonight
that she wants to take a moment to talk
about one of the more important news
stories of the week and she wants to do
it in a very special way
on that great proud morning the sun
arose and shown a brand new light
and finally there was illumination
on just what's wrong and right
the bells rang out and the sweet sweet
sound reminds us we are strong
the notes of those bells reach the
heavens and maybe freedom first their
song
and will it out of cry from the dance of
our souls from sea to shining sea
all our countrymen rejoice cause britney
is free
what i know britney's brief after 13
long years the judge finally ruled the
ender conservatorship wait
that's what this song is about you bet
it is you said you were going to do a
song about one of the biggest news
stories and that's what you're getting
baby
[Music]
no one ever said that life is fair
everybody's gotta take a hit
you get knocked down and you get back up
and yell i've had enough of it
so the next time you think you can't get
it done remember brittany
and
[Music]
let it stir up the joy within the hearts
of lovers
like you and me
all our countrymen rejoice cause britney
is free
so
so
nothing about the climate summit or the
infrastructure bill this is like a
billion times more important
brittany's conservatorship is more
important than the infrastructure bill
thank you i'm glad someone said it
amber i think you're getting carried
away tarik have you ever been held
monetarily hostage for years and years
and then one day you were freed
no okay well let me see if i can explain
it
[Music]
b is for miss spears herself
for how regal she is
everybody knows
please end this
terry
is she not a great performer did she not
dance her ass off with a whole giant
snake at the vmas for your amusement
you never shouted the words to her music
at karaoke from memory
yeah but all those albums all those hits
taric
did britney spears not move you
oh my god
she did
b-r-i-t-n-d-y
and
b-r-i-t-t
e-r-i-t-n-e-y
hit me baby one more time
and we hope this will result in another
vegas
residency
and we'll all line up to get tickets
and she'll actually get paid
by those tickets
just to break in and we'll buy tickets
cause brittany
brittany is free
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign